Let them out
of your sex dungeon.
According to our friends
at the FBI crime lab,
between 7 and 14 people
watching this right now
are keeping a prison
in a sex dungeon.
Whether it's an abandoned
warehouse
where some dudes naked body
is chained to a radiator.
Or just a student nurse duct
tapes to the floor of your van.
But it's the new year
and it's the perfect time
to call olly olly oxen free!
And
Let
them out of your sex dungeon.
Sure, you've got a soft spot
for that young lady.
And it's fun to read from her
from the book of Revelation
while you stroke
your tiny genitals and weep.
And we know
what you're thinking.
Hey, if I let her go,
they're going to catch me,
lock me up,
and throw away the key.
Well, in many states,
that would be true.
But in Washoe County,
our clearing crimes percentage
is about 3%.
So there's a very good chance
we will never find you
or even being to know
where to look.
And Junior, why don't you tell
the nice folks with sex dungeons
out there
what our sheriff's department
DNA crime lab is like.
The Reno sheriff's department
does not have a DNA crime lab.
We do have a mimeograph machine
but we're not allowed
to touch it
because somebody broke it
with their genitalia.
When it comes to letting
someone out of your sex dungeon
The fun is contagious.
Oh why hello America. We here
at the Reno sheriff's department
know that the worst part
of the holiday
is spending time
with your family.
Lucky for me,
this year I'm alone.
My Uncle Buzzy went missing.
I'm pretty sure he just holed
himself up
in his bunker in Truckie.
Oh well, more sweet potato
casserole for me and the cats.
If you weren't able to get out
of being around your relatives
this holiday season,
we have some tips
on how to get
through it peacefully
so things don't escalate
and you don't end up
having to call on us.
That's right, Jim.
Once we've scarfed down
our Christmas pudding
and slipped
into our house pants,
the last thing we want to do
is come break up a fight
between you
and your toothless cousin Ricky
over who's going to drive
grandma to her dialysis
appointment next week.
And now deputies will show you
how a typical holiday scenario
could easily get out of hand
and how to resolve it peaceably.
Could you please pass
the butter, grandma?
Hey what the fuck? Why do you
always start shit with me?
Get him off me! Get him off me!
So this holiday, always have
fresh batteries in your taser.
Or fuck it.
Just call the fire department.
I am the ghost
of Christmas DUIs past.
DUIs you've got
in previous holiday seasons.
Drunk driving
or buzzed driving.
And those DUIs have come back
to haunt you,
ruing your resume,
your chances at child custody,
and your credit rating.
I am the ghost of DUIs future.
If you get one more
DUI next year drunk driving
or even worse,
buzzed driving,
you will lose
your drivers license,
your car, your livelihood.
I am the ghost of DUIs present.
Did you know there are a million
DUI check points out there
this very night to catch you
with your drunk driving.
Or a million times
worse buzzed driving.
Hey guys? Hey guys?
How does somebody change their
ways and not drunk drive again
if we have no Ebenezer
Scrooge and three ghosts?
Not it.
You can't not it.
I don't look good in the hat.
I did it last year
and they put Ebenezer
Screwed on the ...
that's not funny.
It's a little bit funny.
Come on, do it.
Come on, give me the hat.
Fine. I'll be the thing.
Okay.
Oh no, ghosts, you spirits,
show me no more.
I will change my ways.
I will not drunk drive
or a million
times worse buzzed driving.
Wait, stop it. Did they put
the caption up again?
Yep. Ebenezer Screwed.
You think that's funny?